I'm very very pissed about it
how come
how come because I'm paying electric
bills that I've sent you guys all of
them
a homeowner in North Las Vegas says he
got smoked by the Solar Company and
brought his case to the eight news now
investigators we hear complaints like
this a lot from our viewers solar not
working Bill's too high panels put in
the wrong spot but this homeowner says
all of that is happening to him and the
cost of solar electricity is breaking
him financially Kyle Payne joining us
now with the details to explain Kyle
many moving parts to this solar story
many companies many promises many many
regrets
The Story begins like so many do the way
it started was a girl and a guy came to
the front door and they sold John tacona
on solar renewable energy of Nevada says
they're not salesmen but they get the
ball rolling and the taconas signed up
with Titan solar of Nevada which has an
office here in Las Vegas what really
happened was uh they lowballed me the
taconas financed the Hefty cost of
installing the panels which is an 83
monthly payment tacona says renewable
energy and Titan promised his
electricity bill would only be 12.50 the
minimum connection fee to NV Energy but
those bills soared up to as much as 142
dollars he says he's shelling out
hundreds if not thousands of dollars
more than he expected these are what I'm
paying now and there's more before the
switch to solar the taconas were on an
equal installment plans so their monthly
payment to Envy energy would always be
the same amount what he didn't know was
when he made the switch to solar he had
to pay a lump sum of the balance let's
do and he could barely afford it I would
have been better off not doing it also
not doing it is the actual solar product
itself tacona says when he complained to
renewable energy they said the solar
Hardware wasn't enough to service his
house and he needs to buy more panels
but he's already paid for 15 panels and
they want me to add
11 more panels 11 panels will cost him
almost 15 grand in addition to the 26
000 bucks he spent for the original 15
panels he says the panels might even be
on the wrong side of the roof and
renewable energy told him the installers
put panels right where to Kona said to I
didn't tell anybody what they couldn't
do the 8 news now investigators spoke
with renewable Energy's director of
field operations Damien buzz buzz said
someone at Titan misjudged the amount of
energy the taconas use and sold him the
wrong system a spokesman for Titan says
the exact opposite but now tacona is
doing the finger pointing filing
complaints with the attorney general and
other state boards the AG has opened an
investigation and now you don't believe
them no I don't believe them at all
I spoke with a representative from Titan
this afternoon who called me and told me
quote we are definitely going to offer
them a resolution of some sort I can
guarantee you that they are not going to
be paying 14k that's in reference to the
cost of installing new panels to get
their solar working correctly Brian what
it